il y a une maladie qui détruit ton
cerveau et 20 % des français la
contractent euros un jour vos proches en
ont même peut être déjà souffert et
pourtant vous la connaissez très mal
cette maladie c'est la dépression
tu es dépressif arrête ça n'est pas si
simple
vous pensez peut-être que c'est un
problème psychologique d'occidentaux
pourris gâtés que s'il se bouger un peu
tout irait mieux
eh bien non dans cette vidéo on va voir
ce qu'il y a dans le cerveau d'un
dépressif
quelles sont les causes biologiques de
cette maladie sur quoi agissent les
antidépresseurs et pourquoi ils ont une
si mauvaise réputation
on tentera de répondre à tout ça mais
surtout une question brûlante est
essentielle pourquoi l'évolution at elle
gardé la dépression alors que ça nous
est si nocif
vous allez voir la réponse est beaucoup
plus vertigineuse que vous ne le pensez
comment la dépression transforme ton
cerveau contrairement à l'idée reçue la
dépression ça n'a rien à voir avec un
manque de pression ça vient du latin et
ça veut dire enfoncement comme un trou
et le trou c'est pas une métaphore
la dépression va littéralement faire des
trous dans ton fervents regardez la
différence des zones ont carrément
changer de taille
le problème va commencer ici lamic dalle
un cerveau archaïque qui gère la colère
l'agressivité la peur le stress ce qu'il
y a de plus animal en toi si on ne
retire devient tout aussi les gentils tu
ne comprends plus le danger
la rivalité la tension sexuelle tu
deviens inapte à survivre danger à son
extrémité on retrouve campe c'est le
chemin vers la mémoire à long terme si
les deux sont si proches c'est pour une
bonne raison
tué bambi et tu vois un moment se faire
tuer par les chasseurs ton hippocampe
appuyez sur la touche
enregistré et quand tu revois un fusil
cette image est transmise à l'ats me
tall qui est chargé de te donner la
bonne émotion si ça sera du stress elle
va donc lâché dans ton sens une bonne
dose de cortisol ton coeur se serre ton
corps se préparent au combat ou à la
fuite
à ce moment là zone de ton cerveau qui
gère la raison
voudrait prendre le relais sauf que
réfléchir retarderait réflexe de survie
alors en cas de stress
cette zone est plus ou moins débrancher
par l'amygdale si le stress perdure
l'amygdale suractivé s'enflamme et
grossit altérant ta mémoire pas raison
et des émotions positives
c'est exactement ce qui se passe dans la
dépression en étudiant des personnes
dépressives
on se rend compte d'une baisse des
résultats à des tests de logique de
rapidité et à la reconnaissance des
émotions sur le visage ces zones sont
dévorés par le stress j'en ai moi même
fait les frais et je peux vous assurer
qu'il devient vraiment très difficile de
faire le moindre raisonnement même
mathématiques
cette mécanique se retrouve dans
l'alzheimer par exemple ton corps va se
mettre à tuer ses propres neurones et
deviner qu est-ce qu on retrouve parmi
les gros symptômes de cette maladie la
dépression
autant dire qu'il faut prendre très au
sérieux des symptômes dépressifs vous ne
laisserez pas une carie se développer
dans votre bouche alors ne laissez pas
la dépression s'installe et ce qui nous
amène à notre prochaine partie qu'est-ce
que soigne les antidépresseurs être
dépressif c'est un problème de chimie
dans votre cerveau une façon d'agir
serait donc de rétablir l'équilibré au
niveau de l'eau neurotransmetteurs je
vous explique dans votre cerveau il y a
des neurones ces neurones sont reliés
les uns aux autres par des synapses les
synapses ces endroits où l'information
est transmise de neurones en neurones
via des messagers chimiques
ces fameux neurotransmetteur une fois
que l'information transmise
il y a deux choix soit la molécule est
détruite par une enzyme soit-elle airs
capturé est utilisé plus tard
sauf qu'il ya plein de façons pour ça se
passe mal le neurone peut devenir hyper
sensible et surinterpréter les messages
ou au contraire insensible et ne pas
laisser passer la moindre information
les quantités de neurotransmetteurs
peuvent être insuffisante bref c'est le
boxon
c'est ce qui se passe dans la dépression
si un événement banal comme renversé sa
tasse de café tout fait fondre en larmes
c'est un problème de neurotransmetteurs
c'est un événement joyeux te laisse
insensible
c'est encore un problème de
neurotransmetteurs c'est là
qu'interviennent les antidépresseurs les
plus donnés
agissant sur trois neurotransmetteur
bien précis
agir sur la noradrénaline grâce aux
images ce neurotransmetteur c'est celui
de l'action et du mouvement du corps
problème on a observé que certaines
personnes déprimées avait un manque de
noradrénaline on a trouvé une astuce
inhiber la monoamine oxydase normalement
c'est l'enzyme chargée de détruire la
noradrénaline pour l'éliminer des
synapses sauf que là on en manque
on en a besoin il pourra plutôt essayer
de limiter sa destruction le problème
c'est que la monoamine oxydase agit
aussi sur le découpage d'autres
molécules par exemple les tyramine et il
est iranien c'est ce que tu trouves dans
la viande ou fromage en inhibant les
enzymes chargés de découper tu les
laisses s'accumuler dans ton corps c'est
peut être dangereux c'est pour ça que
les imao d'aussi mauvaise presse mode
tête insomnie hypertension c'est loin
d'être anodin 2 agir sur la sérotonine
grâce au prozac ce neurotransmetteur
aide à réguler le sommeil l'appétit et
l'humeur elle il y aussi la douleur on
l'appelle souvent ou l'hormone du
bonheur mais en réalité
son rôle est très floue pas assez de
sérotonine
vous êtes triste vous allez pas faim et
vous dormez mal trop de sérotonine bas
vous devenez agressif sans aucune limite
c'est là dessus que le prozac intervient
en diminuant le système de recapture de
la sérotonine
en gros on va laisser la sérotonine
vivre sa meilleure vie librement entre
des synapses bien dosé c'est parfait
mais un peu trop et c'est le syndrome
sérotoninergiques tous les signes d'une
overdose qui peut être fatale 3 agir sur
la dopamine grâce aux pubs proprio de
neurotransmetteurs et chargé du plaisir
de la motivation et du mouvement c'est
là dessus qu'ils agissent les drogues
libère un max de dopamine vous sentez
bien un manque de dopamine va conduire à
la nedo ni une lenteur dans les
mouvements voir une raideur des membres
ce sont des symptômes de la maladie de
parkinson
c'est pour ça qu'on a essayé de donner
des traitements anti parkinsonien à des
personnes dépressives
ça a marché on sait que cette maladie
atteint spécifiquement les neurones
producteurs de dopamine un peu comme la
dépression 4 agir sur les gabares grâce
au xanax
or c'est un cas un peu particulier si le
xanax et souvent prescrit dans les
dépressions il ne s'agit pas d'un
antidépresseur
en vérité il n'agit même pas sur les
neurotransmetteurs
il agit sur le récepteur d'une molécule
qui est chargé de vous calmez vous
rendre au zen le gaba c'est pour ça
qu'on décrit les gens sous xanax comme
défoncer en favorisant l'ouverture des
récepteurs le xanax ne sert qu'à traiter
l'anxiété qui est un symptôme courant de
la dépression mais il ne pourra pas
guérir la dépression à lui tout seul il
va juste vous détendre et parfois un peu
trop mais comment savoir quel est le bon
antidépresseurs pour me soigner a
justement on sait pas il ya plusieurs
types de dépression qui n'implique pas
les mêmes mécaniques vous pouvez manquer
de noradrénaline mais être bon sur vos
niveaux de sérotonine
malheureusement on peut pas mesurer ce
qui cloche avec une simple prise de sang
les interactions se faisant dans votre
cerveau et pas ailleurs
les médecins sont donc obligés de vous
faire tester plein de traitements
attendre voir si ça marche et si sa
loupe c'est que c'était pas le bon
neurotransmetteur qui peut avoir des
effets secondaires pas coup sûr votre
mental vu que la chimie de votre cerveau
est doublement chamboulé en plus on
obligeait de tester d'autres choses et
beaucoup de patients finissent par
manquer de patience et abandonnée pour
changer ça les chercheurs propose
d'étudier directement le profil
génétique des patients
ils ont regroupé plusieurs études pour
comparer l'adn de personnes souffrant de
dépression avec ceux qui n'en souffre
jamais ils ont alors identifié 40
variantes de gênes qui semblent
contribuer un risque accru de dépression
la question reste complexe car certains
ces jeunes sont aussi liées à des
problèmes de santé qu'ils contribuent ou
sont une conséquence de la dépression
comme l'obésité ou encore l'insomnie
c'est l'histoire sans fin de l'oeuf ou
la poule mais si on arrivait à
identifier des traitements adaptés en
fonction d'un profil génétique l'errance
médical s'arrêterait une autre piste
serait de mesurer les ondes cérébrales
de la personne pendant son sommeil il
semblerait que la bonne réponse à un
traitement puisse prédire en regardant
comment votre cerveau dans la nuit ça
permettrait d'économiser des semaines
d'attentes ça avant de voir si un
traitement fonctionne
mais qu'est ce qui cause la dépression
dans notre corps parce que d'accord on a
bien compris que quelque chose clochait
dans la chimie du cerveau
mais qu'est ce qui est le déclencheur
c'est un virus c'est pas un microbe
c'est juste les émotions non eh bien
figurez vous qu'il existe plusieurs
causes biologiques à la dépression
d'abord l'hérédité la dépression semble
être plus fréquentes chez les personnes
qui ont des parents dépressif avec une
chance sur deux pour être exact on
retrouve aussi ce lien entre les jumeaux
ensuite une autre cause plus étonnante
c'est le microbiote ce que vous avez
dans vos intestins influe sur votre
cerveau vous y avait des neurones il
votre ventre à l'intelligence d'un petit
chien vous y avait aussi des bactéries
qui envoie des signaux chimiques que ce
deuxième cerveau peut lire rigolez pas
ça des effets bien réel vous êtes en
partie manipulés par les bactéries dans
votre ventre quand elles sont pas cool
c'est pas cool pour vous des études ont
montré des similarités de flore
intestinale entre certaines maladies on
retrouve les mêmes bactéries chez des
personnes atteintes de schizophrénie
bactéries qu'on ne retrouve pas chez des
personnes non malades
on a fait des tests en laboratoire en
prélevant le microbiote d'une souris
stressées pour l'implémenter sur des
souris normales
devinez quoi elles sont devenus à leur
tour stressé c'est pour ça qu'il existe
aujourd'hui des transplantation fécale
en gros injecter du k4 quelqu'un d'autre
temps ton ventre pour le faire aux
colonisés par des bonnes bactéries
donc si une seringue de kaka vous fait
pas peur ça pourrait être
potentiellement marcher pour la
dépression troisième cause possible à la
dépression l'inflammation étonnamment
les patients qui souffraient de maladies
inflammatoires chroniques comme la
polyarthrite rhumatoïde ou la maladie de
crohn et est très souvent atteints de
dépression
pareil pour les patients qui reçoivent
des traitements très lourds qui stimule
fortement leur système immunitaire
c'est comme si une fois le corps en
surchauffe votre cerveau finissez par
être à son tour attaqué ce qu'on
remarque en faisant des prises de sang
aux personnes déprimées elles sont
souvent en état d'inflammation voilà
pourquoi des anti-inflammatoires peuvent
parfois aider à soulager certaines
dépressions quatrième cause le manque
d'oxygène
le cerveau est très gourmand en cette
matière il ponctionne 20% de tous vos
besoins en oxygène le cerveau dépressif
semble en manquer mais là encore on ne
sait pas si c'est à cause ou une
conséquence on remarque parc
autre que les personnes qui vivent en
haute altitude où l'oxygène se fait rare
sont plus sensibles à la dépression
c'est pour ça que certaines études un
peu controversé conseil des séances de
respiration et de yoga pour réduire les
symptômes dépressifs
ces quatre causes ne sont qu'une parmi
tant d'autres on aurait pu citer le
manque de luminosité qui agit sur nos
taux d'hormones et de sérotonine l'excès
de stress qui augmente le taux de
cortisol et l'inflammation la drogue qui
met le boxon dans notre délicate chimie
cérébrale et bien sûr les relations
sociales qui sont essentiels à l'animal
social que nous sommes oui pour guérir
de la dépression il reste important
d'assainir son environnement social vers
10 sport aller au soleil bien dormir
améliorer son alimentation et assainir
ses relations l'approchent purement
médicamenteuse ne marche que dans 40 %
des cas
mais voyez au minimum les
antidépresseurs comme des aides pour
retrouver l'énergie d'entreprendre ces
changements s'ils sont possibles
pourquoi la dépression at elle était
gardée par l'évolution on pourrait se
dire que la dépression est un phénomène
nouveau provoqué par nos modes de vie
contemporains
mais non elle frappe toutes les
civilisations à toutes les époques les
anthropologues on le retrouvait des
traces partout même chez les indiens
mayas qui du paraguay un peuple de
chasseurs cueilleurs qui vit isolé dans
les forêts tropicales
elle est même présente sur les animaux
vous déménagez votre chat se met à
perdre ses poils ou à faire ses besoins
partout passez voir votre métaux il ya
des chances que vous repartiez avec une
ordonnance d'antidépresseurs dans les
années 60 une expérience psychologique
assez choquant a été faite sur des
chiens le but c'était de mettre en
évidence l'importance de l'environnement
dans l'apparition de la dépression omis
un chien dans une cage avec un côté
électrifiée et un non électrifiées
séparés par une barrière le côté
électrifié change régulièrement et le
chien fini par comprendre qu'il doit
sauter de l'autre côté de la barrière
pour ne plus souffrir
une fois qu'il a appris ça le chercheur
décide et électrifier les deux côtés le
chien a sauté la barrière est cette fois
rien à faire impossible d'échapper à la
douleur il fini parce qu'ils résident
et il tombe en dépression on remet alors
la cage à son mode de départ
alternant électricité d'un côté puis de
l'autre
sauf que cette fois le chien ne bouge
plus il est persuadé que ses efforts ne
lui permettront pas d'échapper à la
souffrance c'est l'impuissance acquise
c'est horrible cette expérience on est
d'accord et bien le cio l'a utilisé pour
élaborer ses programmes de torture trop
chouette on le remarque la dépression
donc un mécanisme naturel favorisée par
l'évolution
alors est ce que c'est vraiment une
maladie c'est en tout cas une approche
avancée par certains psychologues
évolutionnistes la dépression nous fait
payer un lourd tribut mais qui confère
aussi des bénéfices pendant la
dépression la pensée devient plus
analytique est plus focalisé ce qui
permet de résoudre les difficultés
probablement à l'origine de tout ça les
partisans de cette théorie controversée
ont émis différentes hypothèses
la dépression se déclenche riz pour me
protéger d'infection
quand on est déprimé au ce mouvement
toute cette énergie économisée servirait
à combattre la fiction la dépression
pourrait être un signal d' alerte pour
recevoir de l'aide
si on ne va pas bien l'entourage va s'en
rendre compte et nous apporter l'aide
dont on a besoin
les évolutionnistes pense que cet aspect
fonctionnel de l'humeur dépressive
serait en fait optimisé pour des
problèmes spécifiques main et ce n'est
pas pour autant que tous les états
dépressifs pourrait rentrer dans cette
définition
l'intensité sévère de certaines
dépressions les risques de suicide
associer le handicap social car
représente font penser qu'on ne peut pas
dire que tout les dépressions relève de
ce mécanisme d'adaptation certaines
dépressions sont forcément pathologique
une maladie qu'il faut soigner la
réponse à la question est donc décevante
on ne sait pas pourquoi la dépression a
perduré dans notre évolution rend c'est
juste qu'elle tire ses racines autant
dans la biologique dans l'environnement
social et économique
magic diront certains multifactorielle
diront les médecins si vous n'avez
jamais été atteint c'est difficile à
comprendre comment peut-on devenir si
triste et mou alors que la vie est belle
et qu'il suffit de se bouger et bien non
le cerveau n'en ai juste pas capable
l'être humain n'est pas un être de
raison pure uniquement mû par sa volonté
il est soumis
à la soupe moléculaire à l'intérieur de
sa tête vous pouvez le comprendre
essayer de résoudre un problème de maths
après 48 heures sans dormir
on aura beau vous dire vas-y bouge toi
la lourdeur dans votre tête est bien
réelle c'est pour ça que pleins
d'initiatives sont là pour vous aider
en tapant des pressions dans la barre de
recherche instagram on vous redirige
vers des services d' écoute on vous
donne des conseils pratiques pour ne pas
faire de bêtises
il existe même des applications en ia
spécialement dédiée pour soutenir les
malades
le monde change et j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a aidé à y voir plus clair
un grand merci aux talents de rédactrice
scientifique de julia cette vidéo tenait
à coeur à toute l'équipe
la stigmatisation de cette maladie
aujourd'hui empêche beaucoup de gens de
se faire soigner alors si vous souffrez
appeler de l'aide
faites vous accompagner vous avez le
droit d'être malade
[Musique]
bon